le désespoir c'est un peu de mots pour
qualifier ce type de d'événements 26
décembre 1999 une date synonyme de
désastre pour les agents de l'eau nf en
centre val de loire la tempête lothar
met au sol deux cent vingt mille mètres
cubes de voix une course contre la
montre s'engage
les arbres sont encore verts et peuvent
être commercialisable
ainsi on attend encore un petit peu ils
vont ils vont me le dire ils vont
pourrir les marchands de bois ne
voudront plus il bougeait déjà en poste
à vitry aux loges à l'époque les agents
de l'office national des forêts dégage
routes et chemins forestiers et tente de
sauver le bois qui peut l'être sur le
massif d'un gran il y avait des bois des
parcelles qui était arrivé c'était
arrivé à 80 ans 90 ans de gestion de
génération forestier qui étaient passés
les unes sur les autres et là en une
nuit c'est terminé c'est à dire qu'on
avait que des bois tordus qui valait
plus rien à qu'effectivement c'est
vraiment un crève coeur
c'est un traumatisme qui reste très
longtemps comme cette parcelle décimé il
ya 20 ans est rendu inexploitables pour
trois décennies les stigmates sont
encore visibles en forêt dans d'autres
secteurs les rendements souffre toujours
de la tempête
vingt ans après moi j'ai encore des
parcelles que je parcours en
amélioration ces découpes qu'on fait on
les passait par celle tous les dix ans
aujourd'hui au lieu de retirer les 30
mètres cubes hectares que je devrais
avoir jean n'est que 15e dans les moitié
moins parce que balla la production de
la forêt est encore insuffisant ça c'est
pas sont pas remis de ceux de ce choc
les arbres couchés une plaie pour le mf
en 99 ainsi que pour les gestionnaires
du réseau électrique